o la persona come di stupire perché sto
usando le cuffie che tanto gioco del
telefono ma che ne so bene se noi siamo
tornati su app mobile allora ragazzi
erano rimasti con l'ultimo episodio
fatto con nonno ciak quindi lasciamolo
un po in pausa al nonno e andiamo con ma
veramente lei non ha neanche un nome non
l'ho mai cagate allora con lei abbiamo
dei poteri con la chiamiamo amanda
amanda con le abbiamo dei poteri che non
ho mai sfruttato che sono quella del
salto ok c'è quello del cappottamento in
avanti con consistente perdita di
prodotti del supermarket va bene e poi
c'è quello di andare avanti madonna mia
e ho capito non ci passo ma non ci passa
ormai non ci faccio mai nella vita lì si
sono passato e credibile non è così
facile da comandare lei in realtà non è
così facendo a comandare perché quando
gioco a demis ve lo giuro
sono vivo dicevo quando non quando il
gioco collegio è quindi se non lei non
si muove di striscio quindi meno male
che l'hanno migliorata almeno nella
versione ormai cosa devo fare qua
esattamente che non capisce qualcosa da
fare un certo punto dove vado pensione
ce l'ho fatta giocato c'è quanto già
fatto ce l'ho fatta
avevamo una bella lily proprio buono io
sto facendo quello che mi dice gioco era
alta vado quei suggerimenti che sanno da
che parte vado a destra vai e questo è
il primo livello che non oso pensare
agli altri madonna già un casino
addio addio e che cos'è sono vivo e
successo non saprei neanche come
spiegarlo ma bellissimo ai ragazzi
livello 2 di 5
niente male ho già perso tutto né vero
va beh posso comunque che per livello
che di dati da proprio l'illusione della
serie poi ancora fare qualcosa non puoi
fare il caso ma vado avanti allora
adesso poi salire sull i sali bravo non
ho neanche più il cestino dovrebbe
servire sta cosa perfetto occhio non ho
le braccia ma non fa niente non mi
servono allora ok ok ok ok abbiamo già
secondo me siamo andati quasi alla fine
speriamo di arrivarci non così o dio dio
che ne sapevo che c'era però non si
cammina non so mai cosa fare mai porco
demonio che se se li invece dovevo
starci come un dopo quel countdown
invece no morivo magari era monti con
una specie di propulsione invece non
sono morto io non muoio perché non so le
cose ai ragazzi ci siamo ci ho messo due
ore per ritornare qua quindi non moriamo
per favore mi con anche più siamo a ok
il coso della
devo stare qua non devi stare qua non
devi stare qua non devi stare perfetto
ce l'ho fatta non sopravvive solo
bravissimo madonna che livello il
secondo livello ce ne sono 15 ma è
sempre più difficile questo è il secondo
e sto facendo veramente un casino io vi
assicuro che è impossibile ve lo
assicuro è difficilissimo ma io vado
alla vittoria perché ci credo
tutto a posto tutto a posto che niente
non so non so neanche dove sto andando a
finire non so dove vado mai a mi
chiedevo saltare vado c'ho creduto
perfetto
ragazzo messo due ore due o perché voi
vedete solo i tagli ma giampiero che
taglia un sacco ha tagliato un sacco di
roba poco cattoliche allora terzo
livello corso geometri dei geometri
lascio sua è più il bellissimo l'ora che
incredibile fatto veramente bene
oddio top 10 morti è più il geometria
s'è trasformato in un horror ma va bene
madonna che tempismo orribile ci ho
avuto poi è bello che la dinamica delle
cose che succedono su mobile molto più
precisa che su che su computer questo ve
lo assicuro
secondo avrebbe dato bleach sub l'ici
invece come funziona benissimo
ok ok adesso vado insomma donna che
ansia è stato veramente orribile e pieno
di ostacoli orribili col disco sta tizia
qua mi piacciono poco livelli perché non
capisco che cosa devo fare
e tutta una morte un rischio di morire
continuo ma continua aiuto non sono male
di qua amici per le views ok la madonna
ma stai calmo
stai veramente che cosa succede lì mai
calmissimo ce l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta a
posto
non so cosa sia mick ago non so cosa sia
ragazzi mi sto pagando vado avanti
salta ce l'ho fatta ok non sono arrivato
qua non si possono fare vai piano qua
poi piano piano non so cosa devo fare
non so niente
ok ora tornato giu
ora vivo a posto tutto bene quel che
finisce bene in realtà non è finito un
calcio però posso ancora andare avanti o
che lo aspetta aspetta aspetta ma non ci
arrivo ragazzi non ci arrivo
semplicemente non ci arrivo non c'è modo
non esiste modo non esiste o non esiste
modo di arrivare lì cacchio non esiste e
ragazzi vi rendete conto che non c'è a
meno che non vada più a fini non lo so
oddio no no no no no è sbagliato proprio
morto sono morti nel formato da morto
sto gioco impossibile allora proviamo a
vedere se riesco a fare qualcosa di qua
vedo che comunque non vi siete messi
d'accordo per essere degli stronzi
maledetti di me
vabbè che morte era solo vivo cosa sto
perdendo cosa vedo perché no vabbè sono
sono vivo sono riusciti a sopravvivere a
quella roba diventando un abominio
ma cosa va bene non era così che doveva
andare probabilmente da schiacciarmi e
morino morire ma non è successo
succederà ma fammi vedere semplici ma
anche di nuovo sì ma che è stato
bellissimo è stato più belle bug del
mondo ma cos'è ma non è possibile tutto
il resto e vado dello ski vaste robben
secondo me questo è più facile scommetti
l'altro ci ho messo due ore non ho
concluso una sega queste cose che non è
fattibile
vado di sopra a posto
sono stato bravissimo odio careful maker
fruttuosa dai ragazzi di problemi col
careful ma stavolta careful sul serio
perché su gas molto bene rimani ferma
qua che non dovrebbe colpirti perfetto
vai vai vai vai vai vai careful di nuovo
che funga è impossibile a meno neanche
stando attenti
su gioco non si può finire tu puoi solo
guardare i livelli di rischio carino
questo passiamo al prossimo cioè non
puoi film non si finiscono è un'infamia
continua però riproviamoci dai devo
vedere almeno il quinto almeno a vedere
io mi amava andata affan ragazzi
l'ultimo tentativo in assoluto prevedo
arrivo cioè rating positivo non so come
descrivereste giorgio trovo di vedere
dove arrivò senza pretese anche qui
definisco il video a prescindere ok però
voglio vedere si impegni impegno dov'era
rivisto impegnava che non ha mai visto
impegnando però a prescindere
impossibile fino a qua ok e ci siamo noi
non c'è il carrefour e cioè dopo ok
a posto ma se tu sbagli freccia che
succede non voglio saperlo però meno
male ho cambiato alla fine ti prego
dammi un finale qualsiasi in qualsiasi
bandiera qualcosa è ben accetta
c'è un bottone lo schiaccio dove vado
non ragazzi non so boh
ma le vedove vediamo il quinto ragazzo
un emozionato next questo è il quinto
spero di riuscire a farlo in un
tentativo solo anche se non penso ok ma
da destra amato corro non solo tra gli
amici di ragazzi con la prossima
domenica con alti livelli non con questo
personaggio con un alto quando ci
ritorneremo
spero mai vedremo di fare anche gli
altri per adesso va bene questo
ragazzino seguito e mi piace anche a
vari social che come in ogni descrizione
sei non esisti schiette e non come
sempre ci vediamo al prossimo video
bella ragazza
[Musica]